the political fight over the Iran strike
is intensifying tonight the Speaker of
the House says she will try to limit the
president's war powers he says his
Twitter posts are all the notification
Congress needs correspondent David spot
is at the US Supreme Court tonight where
that battle could eventually end up when
it comes to war the Constitution has
conflicting messages article 2 section 2
states quote the President shall be
commander in chief of the Army and Navy
of the United States but the
commander-in-chief has limits article 1
section 8 says Congress alone has the
power quote to declare war as tensions
with Iran reach a boiling point the
interpretation of the President's powers
is up for debate in a city that relishes
the term the president has every
authority he needed as
commander-in-chief to do it it was the
right decision because American lives
were at stake the president has said
I've got 52 targets I might go after him
I might do it disproportionately I might
go after cultural sites that is war that
is not a response to an imminent threat
yesterday the president put out this
tweet announcing his potential plans to
strike Iran quote such legal notices not
required but is given nevertheless the
president's tweet just doesn't make a
lot of sense Scott Anderson served under
President Obama and was the legal
adviser to the u.s. embassy in Baghdad
the Trump administration doesn't appears
to have coordinated at all with members
of Congress in advance and prior
administrations have generally done so
to some extent but Anderson says the
president and his team still have the
upper hand in many situations the
executive branch has a huge amount of
discretion practically in how it
interprets both its own constitutional
authority and statutes that Congress
might pass to give it additional
authority to use military force December
7th 1941 world war ii marks the last
time Congress officially declared war in
1973 Congress passed the War Powers
Resolution which requires the President
to notify Congress within 48 hours of
sending troops into hostile territory
following the 9/11 attacks Congress
passed the authorization for use of
military force
giving the president broad authority in
specific cases the AUMF as it's known
has been used 41 times in 18 countries
Supreme Court has never ruled directly
on the president's war powers before
legal experts say that is by design to
keep justices out of the fight but hey
Bret it's the Supreme Court anything
could happen behind me okay respond live
outside the Supreme Court David thank
you